going to begin unfortunately with more
troubling images and a new report about
the botched police response to the
uvalde school shooting that city's mayor
has now released body cam footage from
first responders and that footage shows
confusion among some of the officers
about what exactly is happening even
though one policeman told the others his
wife could be among the victims lilia
luciano is in uvalde for us once again
this morning lilia good morning first
comprehensive report to come out what
are we learning
well tony what we're getting is a fuller
picture of the chaos of that
excruciating weight but what we may
never understand is having an
understanding of why it took nearly 400
officers from at least seven different
law enforcement agencies 73 minutes to
take down the shooter i will warn you
the images you're about to see were
edited to protect the families but many
will still find them distressing
[Music]
new body cam footage released by the
uvalde mayor shows the first moments
officers arrived at rob elementary
school
he's really in the classroom he got me
right about four minutes after the
shooter entered rooms 111 and 112 one
officer is graced school police officer
ruben ruiz was heard in the background
recognizing his wife's classroom we got
to get in there
we got to get in there and keep shooting
but seconds later confusion and
misinformation in a different body cam
video from another officer who heads
outside to take cover an alert dispatch
he seems to believe the suspect is
inside an office
he's contained we've got multiple
officers inside the building at this
time
he believe he's
barricaded
in one of the one of the offices
a messed up is still shooting
shortly after the urgency fades and
officers are seen waiting and waiting
what are we doing looking for guidance
what are we doing here
some begin to break windows and pull
students out of the building
by now we see the first images of the
school district's chief of police pete
arredondo sir if you can hear me please
put your firearm down sir we don't want
anybody else hurt redondo and other
officers try to negotiate with the
suspect let me know if there's any kids
in there or anything
[Music]
this could be peaceful
we hear police dispatch alert officers
that a child is calling
from inside a classroom
what was that
close to five minutes later arredondo is
seen heading towards a classroom not
where the shooter was to test keys and
appears unable to open it more minutes
tick by with little action appearing to
be taken by the officers inside the
school besides trying to talk to the
suspect please put your gun down sir
please don't hurt anyone else
and more keys to open the door that
we've come to learn was likely already
unlocked we're testing keys
there were multiple systemic failures on
sunday a texas committee found that the
chaotic scene was caused by a lack of
leadership the committee released a
77-page report which found that those
first responders who went right towards
a shooter's classroom within minutes
acted appropriately at first but all
officers failed to prioritize saving the
lives of innocent victims over their own
safety it also found that the shooter
had a problematic history and even
earned the nickname school shooter on
social media platforms because of
violent threats he would make against
other users if you know there is active
shooting active killing going on or
somebody is dying the standard is
you have to continue to do something to
stop that killing
the report said that there were no
villains that nobody acted other than
the shooter of course with ill motive it
also states that while it's likely most
people died within the first minutes
it's plausible others may have been
saved if police had acted sooner they're
waiting for more medical evidence to
conclude how many tony
all right lilia thank you very much uh
you know lily made that note at the end
the report points out that some victims
died on the way to the hospital so while
they use the word plausible i think
anyone who's even been around an er will
tell you that if you're alive on the way
to the hospital
and you could have gone sooner there's a
good chance they would have a better
shot at saving your life the 77-page
report says quote the void of leadership
could have contributed to the loss of
life the void of leadership just
excruciating to watch the video